[Musique]
dans ce village du haut karabagh des
dizaines de familles préparent leurs
affaires à contrecoeur c'est la deuxième
fois que graphique et susan doivent tout
quitté
à raveneau comme l'appellent les a rien
fait partie de ces villages cédé à
l'azerbaïdjan suite aux accords de
cessez-le-feu en 2020 certains préfèrent
brûler leurs affaires plutôt que de les
laisser aux azerbaïdjanais
ses habitants se sentent trahis et
oublier
ce n'est pas la première fois que ça
arrive et l'argent ne résoudra pas le
problème ce n'est pas une histoire
d'argent imaginez que vous perdiez votre
terre vous devriez vous battre pour elle
cette terre sur laquelle nos enfants
sont nés et ont grandi
les gens écrivent à l'amérique à l'union
européenne
venez nous aider mais l'amérique et
l'union européenne ont mieux à faire il
n'a même pas contre les poutines
la petite arménie le petit karabagh
qu'est ce qu'ils ont à faire
le vieux couple ne sait pas encore
comment évacuer leurs vaches qui sont
leur seule source de revenus ces
arméniens ont reçu l'ordre d'évacuer par
les autorités du haut karabagh poussé
par la brève offensive azerbaïdjanaise
début août les ordres d'évacuation
concernent trois villages du corridor de
latchine un axe stratégique d'environ 5
km de large reliant stepanakert à
l'arménie en dépit de ses pertes
territoriales et des incursions
ponctuelle de l'azerbaïdjan aux
frontières avec l'arménie cet analyste
ne craint pas une escalade militaire
proche mais plutôt une crise humanitaire
l'azerbaïdjan augmente le rythme et la
pression pour rendre les arméniens du
haut karabagh incertains de leur avenir
on l'a déjà vu avec la coupure de gaz de
l'hiver dernier la pression sur les
télécommunications à venir à peut-être
des coupures d'internet
c'est une forme de l'annexion rampante
par l'azerbaïdjan pour essayer de
reprendre avec le haut karabagh to try
to we take
pour aider les personnes déplacés les
ong se mobilisent c'est le cas de all
for armenian qui a repris l'aide
humanitaire d'urgence face à l'afflux de
familles démunies
hovhannès achète de quoi ravitailler
rafic et susan qui manquent de tout dans
leur nouvelle maison
actuellement ils sont dans une situation
ils ont besoin d'équipements de base
pour la cuisine ils sont aussi malades
alors ils ont beaucoup de dépenses en
médicaments c'est pour ça qu'on espère
qu'à l'avenir ils recevront plus dead
que ce que nous pouvons leur donner
devrait y en avoir assez pour un mois
chaque prof
même deux mois je vous en prie
asseyez-vous quand les gens viennent
nous voir et qu'ils sont gentils avec
nous c'est un vrai support psychologique
ça nous permet de ne pas perdre la foi
et l'espoir nous vivons nous survivons
tout le monde est dans cette situation
ce n'est pas juste non
hovhannès par livrer une autre famille
et à quelques kilomètres de là en
déménageant rafic s'est gravement blessé
le dos à 75 ans impossible pour lui de
traire ses vaches
[Musique]
la solidarité passe aussi entre voisins
syrien et ce papy là ils me donnent un
coup de main puis ça va pas me prendre
mon temps pour me remettre sur pied
ils n'ont pas encore eu la force de
déballer leurs affaires la région du
smic frontalière du haut karabagh a
apporté un soutien financier et
logistique pour aider les familles à se
déplacer et trouver un logement parfois
prêtés par des particuliers comme c'est
le cas pour rafik et susan qui
s'installe doucement
désillusionnée et résignés
je savais qu'il y avait désaccord mais
j'avais espoir mais je me mentais à moi
même je pensais comment cela pouvait-il
arriver
le pays a déjà donné tant de terre
comment pourrait-il en donner plus
tant que je suis en vie ce que je veux
voir c'est le karabagh libye
ce qui est fait est fait maintenant ça
va rester comme ça
ils ont dû fuir les turcs ça ce sont
leurs vaches moi je les traits je
m'occupe d'elle j'aide tout simplement
à l'image de maxime de nombreux
arméniens craignent davantage de terrain
ne soit cédée à l'azerbaïdjan
il n'aurait pas dû donner cette route
s'ils ont accès à cette route maintenant
peut-être qu'ils vont venir vivre dans
notre village
on a déjà beaucoup donné demain ils
viendront et prendront la région
d'ararat et doucement ils avanceront à
force de devoir quitter leur terre les
arméniens craignent un nettoyage
ethnique une route temporaire en terre
battue sécurisé par les gardiens de la
paix russes permet le passage de
l'arménie au haut karabagh en attendant
la construction d'une nouvelle route
dont on connaît peu de détails le climat
de peur instauré fonctionnent les
arméniens redoute d'être chassé du haut
karabagh si l'azerbaïdjan en bloquent
l'accès